in Berlin begrüße ich den sicherheits-
und Verteidigungsexperten Thomas Wiegold
welche unabhängigen Untersuchungen
laufenden in diesem Fall
ja unabhängige gar keine es gibt ja
keine internationale Kommission die dort
tätig werden könnte es gibt faktisch
zurzeit nur russische Versuche
offensichtlich die Überreste dieser
Drohne zu bergen in dem Gebiet in dem
Russland ja auch eine gewisse Kontrolle
beansprucht aber mehr ist zurzeit nicht
möglich wie schätzen Sie das ein wie
brisant ist die Situation nach diesem
Ereignis
die Situation hätte potenziell die
Chance sehr brisant zu werden allerdings
haben wir auch gerade im Beitrag gesehen
sind sowohl die USA als auch Russland
bemüht das ganze auf einer politisch
diplomatischen Ebene zu halten liegt
militärisch eskalieren zu lassen vor dem
Hintergrund wenn man den us-aussagen
folgt ein Luftfahrzeug im
internationalen Luftraum und dann
wiederum was die USA sagen durch
russischen Einfluss durch russische
Aktivität zum Absturz gebracht das hat
schon Stoff für Eskalation aber wie
gesagt beide Seiten scheinen bemüht das
auf diesem Level zu halten nicht weiter
eskalieren zu lassen andererseits ist
auch klar Russland sind diese Flüge ein
Dorn im Auge weil die USA und übrigens
auch andere NATO-Staaten mit solchen
Flügen Erkenntnisse gewinnen die dann
sehr wahrscheinlich auch der Ukraine zur
Verfügung stehen
es gab ja auch danach einen weiteren
Zwischenfall britische und deutsche
Kampfjets haben ein russisches Flugzeug
in der Nähe des estnischen Luftraums
abgefangen wie häufig kommt sowas vor
das kommt sehr häufig vor und man muss
diese beiden Ereignisse auch etwas
unterschiedlich betrachten
die russische Luftverkehr Straße
sozusagen von St Petersburg in die
russische Exklave Kaliningrad die führt
über die Ostsee auch im internationalen
Luftraum und das
nato-kampfjets Aufsteigen und zu gucken
wer der lang fliegt ist nicht
ungewöhnlich weil die russische
Luftwaffe sehr oft ohne Anmeldung bei
der zivilen Flugsicherung und vor allem
ohne Transponder Signal in einem
Luftraum unterwegs ist der auch von
zivilen Fluglinien genutzt wird da
geht's dann also eher um die Gefährdung
des zivilen Flugverkehrs es gab übrigens
dann gestern nicht nur diesen Fall wo
die Deutsch britische Alarm heute
Aufstieg von Island aus sondern es gab
einen ähnlichen Fall vor norwegischen
Küste also insofern das ist mehr oder
weniger Routine das wird immer wieder
erwartet und hat eine andere Qualität
als dieser Vorfall über dem Schwarzen
Meer welches Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
gibt es denn damit nach solchen
Vorfällen nicht irgendjemand Fehler
macht und Schlimmeres auslöst
also es gibt verschiedene Mechanismen
für die konfliktion wie das militärische
heißt und unter anderem direkte
Verbindung zwischen dem US
europahauptquartier das jetzt in
Stuttgart und dem russischen Militär
unklar ist allerdings welche Kontakte in
diesem Fall genutzt wurden ob sie
genutzt wurden oder ob es bei diesem
diplomatischen Kanälen geblieben ist das
also der russische Botschafter in
Washington eingestellt wurde es scheint
im keine Notwendigkeit für eine direkte
militärische Konfliktregelung gegeben zu
haben aber solche
Verbindungen die gibt es ist immer nur
die Frage werden sie genutzt und gehen
die wussten auch ans Telefon wenn die
Amerikaner anrufen vielen Dank Thomas
wie Gold bisher besprechen gleich weiter